the Revival of NBC's Night Court became
an instant hit in early 2023 banks in
large part to the return of a fan
favorite character but this is not the
same Dan Fielding here's why much of the
revivals of Po comes from a carefully
considered balance of nostalgia and
likable new elements credit for that
goes directly to Siri star Melissa
Rausch who got the revival going as part
of her deal with Warner Brothers
television there was one link to the
previous series that couldn't be
overlooked John Larroquette his
performance as assistant district
attorney Dan Fielding garnered four
consecutive Emmy Awards for supporting
actor in a comedy series bringing
Fielding back men dealing with a
familiar character's past present and
future all at once Dan Fielding has been
described as many things but in a
nutshell he's a lothario who cares only
about his own desires Nightcore viewers
in the 80s and 90s were often treated to
fielding's exploits with a host of women
while some were humorous others hinted
at a sense of sadness and longing the
assistant district attorney hid All Too
Well re-entry reducing the character
after 30 years offered an opportunity to
delve deeper into who he has become and
avoid treading water with regurgitated
plot points the Night Court Revival
address where Fielding landed in its
first episode judge Abby Stone sought
out the character after losing a key
component to her Court instead of
offering him his old job the new judge
asked him to assume the role of public
defender the first exchange between
Stone daughter of former judge Harry
Stone and Fielding quickly sets the tone
for where he stands Today Gone is the
ladies man who was constantly pursuing
new partners and what remains as a man
Changed by life's biggest Moments Love
and loss that is what sold Sarah on the
place Sarah your wife
she was the former assistant district
attorney revealed that he had indeed
been married finding love with his
deceased wife her last left Fielding
searching for some Solace but only
finding work as a process server the job
kept him near the legal Community
without practicing law some thing he
grew tired of while viewers were away
much like in the original series there's
more than meets the eye with building
with fielding's return also came a new
more modern attitude towards women no
longer was he the man who couldn't
encounter a female character without
making salacious comments he still saw
donik but he's clearly much wiser early
episodes touched on Dan fielding's
current thoughts on dating and love as a
widower with episode 4 done versus
dating offering the clearest picture of
where he is now in the episode a woman
asked him for his phone number but he
initially avoids getting in touch with
her choosing instead to dine alone
Abby's clerk Neil however pushes send on
Dan's drafted text and the woman later
meets him at the restaurant the latter
part of the episode is where the
audience experiences a deep dive into
someone they thought they knew you it
turns out that the woman just wanted a
fling which was actually a cover for an
identity theft Revenge plots related to
an old case so fielding and wittingly
discovers how much his wife's memory
lingers before the ruse is revealed what
would have previously been a one night
stand becomes a strong source of
character development she changed me I
mean the old me would have been very
much into this but I'm a different
manner TV Fanatic Diana Kang
encapsulated what many viewers were
feeling after the episode's debut
writing there is sweeping Romanticism in
the thought of Dan Fielding giving up
his rapscallion ways for the love of a
good woman or maybe the love of the
right woman none of this would be
possible without the talents of John
Larroquette longer games returning to
the role the process of meeting Roush
and seeing what the creative team had in
mind convinced him to give it a try
producing as well as starring in the
series gave him the ability to shape his
character's current Incarnation
something expertly acted in this episode
as well as the entire Revival according
to the actor don't expect Fielding to be
back to his old ways he told deadline
the man is 75 years old nobody wants to
see that and I certainly don't want to
play that so whatever we'll do in the
future about that will always be
glancing blows to that sort of homage
foreign